someone grabbed my chain
and then i just remember seeing knives a
bbc live music event was ended early
last night the rapper crept was attacked
backstage this was a millimeter deeper
and it would have been a different
scenario he's a rapper and has
collaborated with the likes of one and
stormzy
[Applause]
[Music]
stepdad was killed called rana in the
room trying to fight them two more
gunshots everything's silent
we can have a gun retaliate or we take
this music thing seriously actually try
to make it out of where we're coming
from the next thing we put out
went viral skepta reached out and said
yeah we want to bring you guys on tour
it was such a life-changing moment for
us
we started doing radio tv and we started
branching out
full of natural goodness
you would never put a wrapper launch in
a baby skincare line in the same
sentence you should always feel
uncomfortable almost like you shouldn't
be here and that's the growth room and
you can't be afraid of that do you know
what the company's valued at 17 and a
half
what do you think playing with the canal
a baby
cadet whose real name was blaine johnson
has died he was on the brink of doing
something great
what's on your mind
we've got this
complex like i'm not going to cry
like it makes you feel like less of a
man or something i swear
this scares me
so without further ado
i'm stephen butler and this is the diary
of a ceo i hope nobody's listening but
if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
correct
first of all thank you for being here i
think i've got to be honest i think
you're one of the smartest looking
guests i've ever had sit in the chair
i'm very jealous of your outfit today
thank you man it's sick um and the
designer's a friend of mine who um who i
met in manchester a couple a couple of
months back but where i wanted to start
with you is um back in south london back
in croydon i want you to if you can give
me the context in which you were you
were raised and when i say context i
mean like what were those things in your
environment at an early age that
ultimately shaped who you were and left
those little kind of foot those
fingerprints on on your personality and
character
to be honest like when i was
younger when i was in school
like all i knew and all my friendships
knew were you know gangs and
you know
that kind of lifestyle that's all that
we saw like you know everybody that i'll
go to school with or
you know
outside of school that was that's that's
what it was and you know
we got caught up in
a load of nonsense growing up but
i was one of those people
that always
saw the bigger picture and i always
thought i don't want to end up going to
jail and i don't want to end up dying
because that's what i saw like i i've
lost so much friends
due to you know
coming from where we're coming from and
like seeing friends that i've i've grown
up with pass away to violence or crimes
or
you know
friends i've got loads of friends that
are in jail for life
and some for even things they didn't
even do
so i always used to be like you know
when when when my friends was doing this
or doing that i'd always be like you
know i'm going to try and do this and
try and do that and because i do not
want to end up
in jail or dying like that was you know
that's what we was used to like and it's
sad because it's like
it felt so normal like the first time
you know i was like 13
and hearing gunshots outside my house
and coming out and someone's on the
floor dead and i'm a 13 year old young
boy and
it was like it was normal it wasn't even
like
something that seemed abnormal at the
time it just felt like this is
how it is when you live where you live
or where you're from where you're from
and that's what it was you know i mean
and
i feel like i've always
always had my eye on
being more than that like all the time
so
when you know my friends
was
getting involved in certain things
i was like no i'm gonna i'm gonna finish
college i wanna go to university
and i'm gonna try my best to keep
myself you know on a positive path like
and i always thought this all the time
and i always said yeah i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna fall into this trap because
i'm seeing you know my friends falling
into i'm seeing my friends going to jail
i'm seeing my friends die and i'm like
like when is it and it doesn't end it
doesn't stop you know new issues happen
now you know you've got a problem with
these people because of this or like and
it just it's a constant cycle
and i feel like i didn't want to get
trapped in that cycle what was your
family unit like um
my my mum and dad wasn't together
um
my father went to jail for a lot of my
childhood
um
and you know he so he wasn't around
for a lot of the important
moments in my life and that age where i
feel like you probably need you know a
father figure there
um
he wasn't
um because he was in jail
and you know again that's what i was
you know seeing and that was what was a
norm to me you know um growing up my mum
was single and it was she was just you
know doing her best to look after me
and my brother
um and i feel like she's done an
incredible job
but
there was still
i'll never forget there was a moment
where
something happened and
police came to my house
and i never forget my mom said
i failed as a mom
and
i can't explain how that made me feel
and i was like there's no way
on earth
that
i'm gonna let those words even become a
reality
so
i remember from there i was like
i'm going to make this woman proud
like if it's my the last thing i do
and that was a really really big you
know motivational
moment for me why did that matter so
much to you
because
my mum
did everything she could you know she
tried her best
as a single mom she tried her best she
always you know wanted the best for me
and wanting the best for my brother and
you know being a single mom knowing that
his bills and knowing that she was
stressed and this that and the fourth
like i know she wanted the best for me
and me feeling like
you know
i haven't even tried to
appreciate or repair for that and her
feeling like a failure even though she
done her absolute best
so
that resonated with me and it really hit
me when she said that
and
yeah from i remember from then like the
motivation i had i was like i'm going to
because i i didn't even want to stay
in uni or i didn't want to like i was
thinking that that's long i don't want
that
and i was like no i'm going to go all
the way and i'm going to graduate i'm
going to make her run and shake my son's
got a degree i'm gonna do that and i'm
gonna do my music and i'm gonna be
successful in that and she's gonna be
proud i spoke it and knew it was gonna
happen because i was so determined from
from there to make it happen so
yeah
often when you're from an environment
where people are being tempted to
choose a
nefarious life so when they're being
tempted to choose a slightly you know
maybe it's a criminal lifestyle or
something because they don't have the
same level of opportunities in that
environment so
often people look back and they can
almost see how it could have gone
another way for them how they could have
been tempted in that other path because
there's no doubt temptation to choose
another path would have been present in
that environment when you look back on
on those times can you can you see how
things could have gone another way 100
like
there
there was you know
there was one
specific moment that um
i remember when
it was when conan
had a situation where he's his stepdad
was killed
and his mother was shot can you tell me
about that incident what yeah you read
about that in a song yes a song called
my story um where
conan was um we think it was coming back
from radio
and
conan
um
when conan got back
basically there was people waiting for
him
and
he
was walking to his door
and he had his key in his hand
and he's always been a paranoid person
so he's always like
ready to put his key and then because
like he was always alert and he always
he's just an alert person he's always
alert on point
and if this was probably anybody else
they probably would have died
but
he was just by his door and then he
heard
people running behind me and he just
knew straight away he didn't look back
he just put his key in the door turn it
open it closed it
and then
that's when you know
he realized like okay someone is
definitely here to try and kill me
and they've got in the house
um and
they've basically when they're holding
the door upstairs
um they've shot through
the door
and one of the the bullets you know hit
conan's mom
and then
conan's stepdad at the time
ended up wrestling with them and then he
ended up getting shot
um and and dying
and then
um
the guys left but
you know it was
that situation that happened and as you
can imagine what that
what effect or you know that would have
had on him
and everybody around him so
i remember we were sitting in a car
and
our friends was like
look
we can have a go and do this and and
retaliate or whatever whatever it was
and i remember there was that moment of
oh we
we
take this music thing seriously and
you know don't throw everything away
right now and actually try to make it
out of where you know we're coming from
and there was that moment of like
we're gonna do the music
we're gonna focus and put our all into
this
and you know see what happens and that
was like
a moment where that could have easily
gone a completely different way
like we literally had nothing we i
remember we had an argument over the
last bit of chicken and chips
because that's the only money we had
like we had nothing
and conan was homeless like it was like
probably the one of the worst periods of
our lives and definitely conan's for
sure
um
and
i feel like
from there
we done
otis which was like a
cover of jay-z and kanye's
um song
and
that song
went viral
and
it was like
it was the perfect time for something
like that to happen
because we could have done that
and not done what we've you know not
done anything and then we could have
just you know somehow slipped back into
or whatever but
it was literally from that moment
the next thing we put out bearing in
mind we've been putting up music
you know and we've never had a moment
like that before and the next thing we
put out after this
disaster
has just happened
the next thing we put out
went viral
and
everything changed from there literally
you know
we put this out
and then from there
we ended up you know skepta reached out
and said you know we want to bring you
guys on tour
and you know for any musician when you
go on tour and do live music it's like
for the first time
it makes you feel like you're really a
musician like i'm really doing this for
real and
that was really like a a special moment
for us that he's asked us to come on
tour during this period we was we were
so new as artists skepta didn't you know
we would have just done the tour for
free he didn't even
he didn't even just have us on the tour
supporting he paid us
like he paid us per show like and when i
mean we were so we was like we're gonna
get paid to come on tour with you on a
tour that is already sold out
he didn't need us there
and he had us on on the tour and paid us
as well and it was just like such a
life-changing moment for us like
you know
i i i just feel like that that
the stars are lined or something but
you know being in that moment where
you're like about to throw everything
away
to
then
you're
on stage live with thousands of people
in front of like
from that transition to that in in
you know you couldn't make that up like
that was just
it was just a crazy time and i feel like
yeah man i feel like we obviously made
you know the right decision and
yeah we've never looked back since man
the person that um carried out that
attack
um
did you ever find out why they did it
and did they get caught
it's
it's weird because we don't actually
we'll never know who
who done it because you'll never know
who done it now because we
there was two people there
all right um and one person got arrested
for it but
at the end of the day you still don't
know
you know
you've done it and they got sentenced
yeah they got sentence i think they got
found with
the weapon or something like that
but um
yeah there was two so we don't actually
know
[Music]
who's who's done it
up until today
we know a lot about mental health these
days it's more of a conversation now
but how does
you know you're by his side how does
conan deal with that
both of his parents being shot one of
them dying
conan is like
i it's one of those ones where i can't
even explain
on his behalf
because it's not even something i can
even comprehend
being in that situation
um what i know
we have done is you know stayed
doing music and doing what we love
and
actually growing in that world and
actually you know becoming someone from
doing what we love and
you know the success that it's brought
and all of you know the great things
that have happened and you know us just
growing and growing and growing
i feel like that has been
a major distraction from the harsh
reality of what's happened in in his
life do you know what i mean and
um
i feel like
if we didn't
you know have the success we had i don't
know what would have happened
there's it's interesting because
i'm not sure if success um
success heals like you use the word
distraction it's actually the word that
i would naturally use it kind of
distracts you from the pain and then
what you tend to see when i sit here
with a lot of people is they they still
have to at some point address that
address that pain or alternative alcohol
or other exactly yeah
um and we see that a lot with musicians
especially you know
so that's kind of what i'm getting to
you've been through the same you've been
through the same hurt and you've lost
people in your life as well so you can
kind of speak to that as opposed to
speaking the current situation but how
especially in like
in that culture in like the black
culture and especially black men they
don't talk about mental health
really especially ten years ago no
[ __ ] chance no no no it's like
we've got this
i don't know complex or we've got this
thing where we're like
oh we're all right like i can get
through it like i'm not going to cry
and i don't know
why
or how or why we've been conditioned in
this way but
we have and we feel like you know we
don't need to talk to anybody about
feeling down
like it makes you feel like less of a
man or something i'm not sure what it is
but
you know
it's definitely something that's
important to me because
like my one of my best friends committed
suicide
and
i have no idea
why up until today
so talking about nash
yeah
and i don't know why like
the last time
i was with him we were celebrating that
we just finished the shop
like bro we did it and he was like i
can't believe we've done it we've done
it and he was so happy and then he was
showing me like look at the emails i'm
getting from people like that showing
interesting he was so excited about it
but then
a few days later
he jumped in front of a train
like
what was what did i miss
i was with him spoke to him all the time
like and it was just it was like
and we're like this and he didn't not
once
express or make me feel that he was
depressed or going through something
mentally like i didn't know
and i'm with him
every day
i didn't see it
so that's how i know how important it is
you know for us as men and black men
to you know really
not you know hide and cover and
you know in our feelings and our
emotions and there's nothing wrong with
talking about it or telling someone or
going to therapy like there's nothing
wrong with that i feel like
i don't know why i don't know why but
that situation made me realize how bad
is
because i genuinely didn't see anything
wrong with him
like
we're speaking all the time he's
updating me look what this has just
happened i'm going here i'm going there
i'm doing this like oh this is just
coming to the shop got this order like
we're like
you know and then we celebrated the fact
that we finished the shop and it was
built so for context here you this is
when you launched um crepes and cones
yes so
before launching crepes and cones nash
was the person that was going to
run it and manage the store and for
anybody that doesn't know so
i kind of heard the story that someone a
fan had tweeted you guys one day about
how funny it would be or something that
if you open the restaurant called
um you trademarked it or yeah no i
basically i
i can't remember i had a conversation
with someone one time on it and like i
remember that the name came into my head
and then
i just tweeted one time right i tweeted
in 2014 i said one day
we're gonna have a restaurant called
crepes and cones
and i just thought it was a sick idea
sick name six player for the name but in
2014 i never had anything so it was it
was it was just what it was a really big
just putting it out there by the way one
day i don't know if this ever going to
happen because you know i'm not in a
position to make this happen but i feel
like i will be one day and i just put
out the tweet and then i saw people like
oh that'll be sick that'd be sick loads
of retweets i'd be sick
and then it was like
okay one day like we'll revisit that
conversation
and then um did you trademark it i
didn't you know that's nice i didn't i
just did no one did luckily we
trademarked it a bit later down but we
did we didn't even
i don't think i could afford to
trademark yeah at the time like i don't
even think i could have afforded to at
that time when i when i tweeted it but i
remember
um speaking to nash about it and saying
yeah one day like
you know i'm
this is what we we need to do this one
day and he said i'd be sick that was
sick but he was working in property and
he was doing really well doing what he
was doing
and
i remember he called me and he was like
i wanna i wanna
you know it's time for change man i
wanna do something else
um what about the idea that you were
saying
the crepes on counting
and i was like
yeah
let's do it and this was at a time when
i i could do it and you know
and conan was like yeah this like he he
already it was something that we wanted
to do you know i mean so
um it was just like who are we gonna get
to lead this for us because obviously
we're musicians we need someone that you
know and
when nash broke down you know everything
that he had been researching learned and
you know people that he was going to get
bored to be a part of it and this time
the fourth it was just like this makes
sense let's do it and there's no better
person to do it with than
one of our best friends you know what i
mean
and so we decided yeah we're going to do
it
um
and
yeah that was a
nightmare in itself like
you know just
building a shop like having builders
going missing or
you know
people trying to be middlemen skimming
off the top and this down and forth and
taking advantage of you because you're
musicians as well right so we i probably
ended up spending triple what
we should have spent on building it
um and it took like a year like when i
mean me and nash was probably sleeping
in that shop there was days we had we
did sleep in the shop because we you
know we had two deliveries and the next
day and you know we need to get this
done and you know we need to do that or
do this and
and then we we didn't trust any builders
we didn't trust anyone so we had to be
there while they was doing it to make
sure they're doing it
in a way that we told them they're going
to do it you know because we'd leave
them they'd come back and then
something's not done or and it's like
what have you been doing in the last
week and it was
and it was just it was a it was a
probably just the worst like
you know experience in terms of
our intro into this business world uh i
i hated it like i was i'm not going to
see her and say like yeah it was great
and it wasn't i hated it i put my back
up and it was like okay i don't i don't
i know stepping into this world i'm not
going to trust anyone now and that
really that restaurant really changed me
as a a businessman really changed me as
a as a the way i think and you know the
way i approach things and
in terms of like
before if somebody would come to me and
say this is how much this cost to do
this
i would probably be like
okay sounds reasonable let's do it now
i'm going to ask 10 other people i get
other people to ask another 10 other
people
and gauge if this makes sense and this
is the right thing to do or not or i'm
getting the best value for money before
i wouldn't do that and i do that with
everything it's like i'm i'm
double checking everything every aspect
is this the best kind of
thing to do or is there a way i can do
this in a better way for the same price
it and it's just made me like that and
it i feel like it's turned me into a bit
of a monster not a monster but like i'm
just really not the same person i was
when i was making you know crepts and
cones that's what adversity does though
you build a callus and that becomes like
self-defense right so more than anything
you want people to know that you're
gonna ask those ten questions before
they even come to you because then they
won't they won't try it so you're
playing self-defense which is what i do
as well it's like if you know i'm gonna
ask 10 questions you're not going to
give me the the bad price the first time
you come up because you know because you
know every time i interrogate it even if
i end up saying yes i'm going to ask you
all kinds of [ __ ] yeah i get that a lot
now like from people that i use and work
with and they're like ah here he goes
again tangents and asking 101 questions
and i'm like double checking everything
and but that comes from experience of
yes being burned or being burnt yeah and
we felt like we was burnt really badly
on
crepes and cones what did it teach you
about business because that was your
first rule like foray into business i
mean you had like the apparel brand
before then yeah we done we done we sold
like a lot of merch which done which
done right that was what actually helped
us make the money to invest in our music
so the dude selling the you know the
apparel the merch and stuff like that
that's what we actually ended up getting
money from to invest and do music videos
and do that independently but what's
that that cause that experience setting
up a restaurant i mean i used to work in
a restaurant when i was done my mum's
restaurant when i was young
eight nine ten eleven twelve things the
chaos of customers
like
that that because people someone said to
me when i was like i'm doing a
restaurant it was like that's like the
hardest business to get into what are
you doing to make money and i was like
really like i didn't
and then
it it became
extremely harder for us because you know
nash was our guy and
you know us having nash getting the
staff hiring everybody dealing with
everything counts this that and the
fourth and he was our guy leading this
and then
the week we're
launching on the saturday that earlier
on in that week he commits suicide take
me back to when you found out that that
had happened
it was i think it was like someone was
coming to the shop to do something i
can't remember what it was but i was
doing an update
from
nash on something to do with the shop
and
um
didn't hear from the whole day
and i was like this is odd because he
would usually
update us on everything like god this
has happened and he was so excited i ah
imagine this has happened i found it i
found the sickest bartender oh my god i
found the secret chef look look and it
it was just like loads of that usually
and we're a week away from
you know
launching we couldn't hear from him the
whole day and he was like
where where is nash like wow have you
got through to him and arsenal what's
going on
and
you know we're messaging him trying to
call him
um
and then
um
we were when we was at the restaurant
um
yeah i got a call and someone was like
it's nash
and he's dead and i was like
and he was like he jumped in front of a
train
like
i'm even more confused because
one of the last interactions we had
we was walking across the road
and i remember the bus was coming and he
grabbed me and was like get out of the
road like what are you doing
like he's like i remember him going bro
don't do that you scared me like that
kind of thing like the bus was coming
and he grabbed like it was
a moment of
oh the bus was coming
like straight away
i was thinking about that there's no way
he did that because i remembered like
why would he do that how
what was wrong why didn't we see it like
there was so much questions
like and i just remember breaking down
outside not in here like
tears crying i was like there's no way
this is real
and then
we was gonna just cancel the the launch
and then
someone close to him was like he
wouldn't want you to do that
and we made a decision said you know
what
we're just gonna do it
um we ended up having to find you know
all the people the stuff people that he
was contacting and trying to get hold of
them to keep this thing going for launch
um and i managed to kind of get majority
but not everybody or everything in line
that he had prepared
we're grieving
and we're launching
and we don't know what we're doing
all at the same time
so
and the day is launch day you know we've
got the mayor of croydon coming down
cutting the ribbon at the shop and the
whole time i'm thinking about nash
like
that should be here
we're taking a picture
that should be in this picture
like when we open these doors i don't
even know what's going on so people
thought we was there because of pr and
we're in a restaurant seven people doing
this doing that no he wasn't i wasn't in
there because of pr i was in there
because i had to be in there had to work
in there i had to like i was
literally working in that restaurant
you know cleaning toilets where you name
it i was doing everything you know
and people thought it was a pr thing i
was doing it for piano it genuinely
wasn't like i didn't know what i was
doing
and it was it was scary man like it was
like
we've literally just launched this
massive thing the queue is from here
till
the end of the road like i've never seen
anything like it the queue was so long
and it's like all these people are
coming to eat here
oh my god and you know we're going
through this and you know it was it was
it was like a bit of sweet
but mainly bitter because you know it
was
you know in a restaurant world you're
dealing with people's emotions
you're not dealing with you're forget
your emotions you've got to deal with
the staff's emotions you've got to deal
with the customer's emotions
if your chef is not in a good mood today
he's now going to burn this rice or he's
going to do something maybe out of
character or something
um
and
so i've got to rely on my chef's
emotions every single day even if he's
going through his own issues or and it's
not just one chef there's two three four
then you know if you're
your main bar person it's a saturday
busy night decides i'm not turning up
for work because they've had an argument
with their partner or whatever it is
what do what do i do so this whole
business is relying on other people's
emotions and even the customers the
customers come in they're not in a good
mood
they're already just
i'm not in a good mood i want my food
and i want it in five minutes and if i
get it in seven minutes i'm kicking off
but just because they're in that mood
so you you're constantly dealing with
emotions and people's feelings every
single day and for you to get that right
every single day and everybody's
emotions be great and everyone's in a
great like well you're still dealing
with your own right and we're grieving
do you know what i mean and
i remember covering happened and then it
was a
slack it gets even worse
and our restaurant was
you know
it was about coming in their vibes and
experienced music drinks this that and
forth and that was
what it was so it wasn't like takeaways
like you know everyone's like yeah just
adapt and do takeaways yeah that's fine
but
our whole
business was built on vibes and we did
we did like sunday events i mean like it
was really an in person that's what we
created but the restaurant done so well
it managed to you know survive
throughout the cove stuff
but
then
we was not going to reopen because
of the stress and what it was doing to
us mentally
i didn't care about the money
you know people like you're sitting on a
gold mine you get this right just to get
right and you know you can
and i was like i hear you
sounds great
i can't deal with it that is too much
stress that like i was in there every
day i was losing weight i was i was
drained tired
you know i remember a guy came in and
stole everything because he pretended to
be a friend of ours and the staff that
was working there or the cleaner
believed him and was like yeah your
friend came in and took all the ipads
and all the
equipment and i was like what what why
would you what are you talking about and
then gone in there there's nothing that
like they've taken all the stock it's
that it's like what is going on like
this is this is crazy i can't do this
and it was just like i'm not
i don't care what potential this has
i'm not doing it and
then
um
my my friend
bouncer introduced me to
some guys and said look these are some
really good guys
you know they've got these successful
restaurants they've run it amazingly and
this down and forth and you know they're
interested in partnering up with you
guys to just you know make this work
because
you know you you clearly got something
here and these guys came and they said
look we'll we'll deal with that we'll
take away what a headache let's let's
let's make it work man we
you know we see and we see this being
big we feel like we can franchise it we
feel like we can do this down the fourth
was that
cool let's do it let's give it another
shot
um um as long as you know i don't have
to bear
that that
the brutal
reality of you know running a business
running a restaurant have you ever have
you ever um
have you ever like truly taken time to
because you used the word grief we were
grieving what does that actually look
like when you say we were grieving
because from what from what i'm guessing
it and from my assumption of hearing the
story it seems like
your version of grieving has always been
to just kind of distract yourself that
is literally what i do and i just feel
like
and i don't know if i feel like i'm
scared to
stop
and take everything in
so i've always keep it
i'm just like oh that's happened gotta
keep going because if i stop
and and i don't know if that's a recipe
for disaster or not i'm still waiting to
find out i don't know
when when nash passed it was like i felt
like okay i've got to make this work now
i've got to make
crepes and cones work because what this
this like he'd done so
much
and we spoke about so much and you know
this can't just die in vain i feel like
through the stress
that was one thing that made me just
feel like you know i'm just gonna you
know i'm just gonna do it i'm gonna do
it it was only
being forced by covid to stop
everything where i sat down and was like
just do i want to start this [ __ ] again
yeah do i want to do this again
do you know what i mean but what kept me
going was
that and
yeah how are you feeling though when
because
again you know you keep yourself busy
you keep yourself distracted but what's
going on behind the mask like underneath
the hood everyone on the surface you
know you you're keeping up appearances
to keep things the ship moving but how
are you actually feeling like when you
go home at night and when you do have
those moments yourself in the car like
how are you feeling
believe it or not
i don't really have their moments
like i literally will be trying to do
something until i'm tired and go to
sleep wake up and continue doing it
again like i don't feel like i've sat
down
and taken in everything that's happened
i don't think i've
and i swear it scares me because
i'm like you're taking in so much you're
taking on so much
and all i do is just you know keep
working i keep doing this i keep doing
that
but then i feel like you know
i've got a lot of positive
you know even i don't call it
distractions because it's my life
so i'm not really being distracted
because this is my life and this is what
comes of it and this is what i'm doing
and this is what i love doing
and i'm doing that
but
at the same time i am dealing with a lot
of
grief like a lot of it and
i haven't sat down
and you know taken it all in
and said like
wow like how am i feeling because i'm
always just trying to
distract myself i guess but have you
ever seen moments where that grief all
that all the things you have been
dealing with have
caused your behavior to change in an
unpleasant way that sometimes is one of
the like the indicators that there's
something there's something underneath
going on kind of like what you said
about yourself just you know there's
when you're dealing with things maybe
the first thing that might go i mean
some people start self-medicating with
alcohol or whatever it might be but then
other people you just see changes in
their behavior they might get a bit more
angry they might be a bit more cold a
bit more distant a bit
you know what i mean have you ever have
you ever seen any of those symptoms in
yourself because of the grief
yeah i think the cold
um
and
i feel like
i've dealt with so much
i'm not dealing with this
and i feel like so when something
happens when i feel like i'm not dealing
with it
i'll just switch off
you thinking about like relationships
friendships
whatever it is like it's not you know
whether it's business
whether it's making a decision that you
might not have made
before i felt like
you know i might have been too nice here
or been too nice there and just
everything's just made me feel like
you know i've been through a lot more
i'm not gonna make you add to my stress
or make this add to my stress
so
i'm really quick to just dismiss things
or you know and i feel like
i've i've become a little bit more cold
to it because i'm just like
i'm not gonna deal with that i'm not
gonna
it's almost like i'm protecting myself
from feeling any more hurt
or
emotion that's one strategy isn't it
just a numb
life
yes just like i'm like oh negative vibes
oh this is no no
no i'm just like this and i feel like
you know
anything that i feel is remotely
negative i'm just like i'm out
that is probably a good short time
strategy in some situations but over the
long term again there there's probably
probably a cost especially now that
you're a father right yeah and one of
the things you're trying to instill into
your own child is probably like
emotions and understanding your emotions
and that is okay to feel and and even go
the other place i you know
i think people often see is in their
like romantic relationships
when you're in
because
men and women have a different uh way
about them emotionally yeah definitely
typically right and so
um women are typically more in touch
with their emotions
and men are typically less in touch with
their emotions at least that's a broad
stereotype so sometimes can make it
difficult when a man has like numbed
himself to deal with stuff to then be
able to emotionally connect with some a
woman in the way that i'm talking about
myself as well here
that she
she needs in order for you to speak the
same language if you know what i mean
yeah when you're when your music career
started taking off and all these crazy
things start happening um
in your own estimation what was the
moment where you go that was meh
everything really really changed when we
dropped that
um everything really really changed otis
was like a partial change that was like
this the first lift off that was the
first liftoff but it was like okay
what's next then yeah and then the next
big moment that we had was when we
released our project called young kings
it was like our
independent mixtape that we done
um
and we got a guinness world record for
it for being the highest independent
charting album
18th or something was in it yes like 18
years like top 20 and was like and that
was before streaming crazy so that was
just you know based on physical people
buying it and
you know that was a real like
whoa moment for us because just before
that like that period after otis and
before young kings
we was dealing with so much rejection
like in terms of not even just rejection
but
you know people saying ah maybe you
should put a girl in your group and you
can be like ndubs and maybe that might
work out for you or have you tried the
ant and deck thing like just being
comedians or
like it was bare of like just loads of
people
you know
just
giving us their projections of what they
think we should be and it just felt like
they wanted to just
chew us and spit us out kind of thing
and and that's what it felt like and
you know we started then trying to make
records to please
what the radio wanted or you know what
we felt would have got on tv
and
then
we sat down i remember we sat down with
skepta big up skepter again we sat down
with skepta and he was like yeah man
like
the labels man they're not they're
they're trying to make us do this or
they want this sign of sound and i
remember skepta said just skepta on
jammer this was in skepta's house and he
was like
forget
radio forget tv
forget record labels
just do you
do whatever it is that you want to do
there's independent pluggers that will
plug you to radio themselves you don't
need a label to get do all of these
things just do it yourself put it out
yourself like don't watch and then
they're gonna come to you and never
forget that they said they're gonna
start coming to you that was like a
really important moment for us where
we
released our project and the music that
we made was just like what we wanted to
make
and
you know we made don't waste my time
and when we made don't waste my time it
was like it was purposely made to be
like
yeah we don't care what anyone has to
say this is the music we want to make or
we're going to say what we want to say
on the song and you lot can't tell us
anything i'll never forget when we put
it out it just went crazy like the song
started going everywhere performing it
then you know the song ended up on
um creed the movie
and like you know out to bellows
entrance song like it was a massive
moment in creed
and it was like
we've done all of this with a song that
we knew like we just thought this is
this is what we want to do don't waste
my time yeah that was don't waste my
time and we was just like
yeah like and then
as scepter said everyone ran into you
now everyone was like oh my god i'm
gonna sign
record labels left right saying oh my
god like for a checkbook so yeah we want
you we want you and then it just really
was like a it was like a really 360 and
and then
we started doing radio and you know tv
and we started you know really branching
out and people were like how did you get
into that but the reason why we how is
because we always
over deliver
on
little opportunities
so
we got a radio opportunity to do to with
apple to do a show that they've been
doing with everyone so not everyone but
like i select a few of us everybody gets
i think like six
episodes
um and then they move on to the next
size
we ended up on episode 36 or something
but it was because
we was like we got this opportunity
we know how everybody else has done
these shows and what they're expecting
which is they're not expecting much from
us
but what if we
make this a sick show what if we go out
of our way bring other guests on
have games just do fun let's do fun
things let's make this entertaining and
actually make the show a good show
and
that's what we did so our show was
nothing like what they expected we went
above and beyond we had everybody coming
on our show from americans to swiss
french to you know the daves to aj like
everybody's come on our show and
we didn't have to do that we didn't get
any extra to do it we just said we're
gonna you know take this opportunity
and
make the most of it and from that you
know they kept offering us more shows
and more shows and more shows and then
someone you know brought up the the tv
show the rap game and said like who do
you think and because of our radio show
and like it was like no these guys would
be great for this that opportunity came
to us and someone recommended us to do
the rap game and then we ended up in tv
but that was all because
we just put that extra bit of effort in
a small opportunity and i feel like a
lot of people
you know
don't even think like that like some
people think
there's an opportunity here
this is what's expected of me this is
what i'm gonna do
and i just don't
i just don't live by that and conan we
don't live by that because
i feel like if you over deliver and show
what you actually can do in any
situation
what can come from that is going to be a
lot more
and it's always worked
it's so true that you can take a
when someone presents you with an
opportunity they're actually it's almost
like they're actually what you see there
some people will see an opportunity but
what you're actually if you look behind
the opportunity is a set of dominoes yes
then if you flick the first domino and
you succeed in the first opportunity
there's this cascading set of
opportunities that arise from it but if
you don't do a good job on that first
domino hitting that first domino hard
enough you'll never
start the sort of you know the knock-on
effect when i see that in everything
that i've done even becoming a dragon
or you know because it's very easy when
you become a dragon just to fall in just
to fall in line right just to sit there
yeah but for me it was like here's an
opportunity for me to really try and
express myself
i notice that when i watch it i'm just
like i'm so glad yeah he's just being
him and saying like what he truly feels
and not just
like he's sick to siege you know what
i'm saying because it's funny because i
it wasn't i'm not saying i'm not saying
it was a
maybe it was a little bit conscious but
my thinking is look i'm gonna i i can
get kicked off the shirt any time i
might as well like do it my way and have
a bit of fun with it and at least like
leave a mark because the dragons in the
past that i've like resonated less with
are those that didn't show the full side
of their personality and acted too much
like a dragon and acting like a dragon
to me is it
is like sitting there and just like i'm
out
like i like your business that's good
i'm going to invest so for me it's like
well in reality my personality's a bit
more diverse than that so exactly so
people watching that will see like
there's more to him than this paul
dragons thing and then you know other
opportunities are gonna and they have
it's crazy and i i swear i live by that
i genuinely do i feel like
don't see something because for what it
is
on on the surface and face value just
there's a lot more that can come from
this if you really just put in a bit
more effort money
money starts coming in for you in your
life
people don't teach us anything about
money i mean you did go to university
for accounting so i thought maybe you
had a bit of an advantage there but i
don't even know if that's true i just i
just saw it in your in your cv and
thought oh maybe that helped him but
money coming in nobody teaches us what
to do with it especially in i think i
gotta say i think in the in the like
hip-hop community there's a lot of
narrative around like go and get the
go and get that car go get buy this
watch or go by this shiny thing and i
also think that sets us back as well
that's something that's i've always
in more recent times when i started to
understand money and how it works and
i've met billionaires and i've met
people that literally their careers are
just playing money games where they
understand how to get this money and
double it and they have all and they
also have access so they get the deals
first if airbnb is going to go into the
stock market they'll get a 50 discount
it goes public the next day they sell
the next day and they make double their
money so it's access but it's
information
and i just feel like you know we
a lot of people have been deprived of
that information so when you start
getting money in your life what's your
relationship i agree 100
because there's things that i just found
out about that
i just didn't know existed and it's like
why don't we know this
you know um but like i feel like it
starts from
school i feel like there should be a
class in school that teaches you
on this like just things like credit
there was something
uh you need is like you get some 750
pound overdraft thing or whatever
and then i was like i was 750 pounds
yeah
yeah like great and then they're chasing
what are they gonna do they're not gonna
do anything i'm not going in jail
and then but like it was just
not knowing that this stuff actually
affects you for years to come
and it's like you don't know just even
paying fines or whatever it is like yeah
there's things that you know this if you
don't do this or you don't pay this or
it's gonna affect you in the long run
yeah and i just never knew and i'm
someone that would if i knew i heard it
once
that's it i'm never gonna i never knew
my first car was a range over sport and
it was they wouldn't let me put it in my
name
so i
my business partner had because he had
credit he put it in his name and then so
i was driving around in this range of
sport living in a seven bedroom house
with the tennis court and my cr honestly
they wouldn't lend me to a jaquid
because i destroyed it when i went to
uni i dropped out of uni straight away
but i'd gone and i'd got these
overdrafts i just blowed over
set you up for it like i swear
it's like because i know so much people
that's gone down that same university
path of they offer you this big shiny
750 pounds like that you don't have to
pay back it's just you do have to pay it
back but you have to pay it back but
like the way they coat it is in like you
know free money it's a trap that we fall
into because we don't know the
consequence of if you don't do this then
this happens and i just feel like
it stems from us
i feel like this being something that we
should learn
at
in school like you know before we start
taking credit out and start doing things
that affect our credit we should be
learning about it but there's nothing
that you know really teaches you that in
school that
and you know all my peers or my friends
and none of us knew nothing about credit
and i just think why is it like so
hidden or why is it not really projected
is it a parent's role to turn them about
credit and you know i feel like it now
it is because it's probably become a lot
more of a thing nowadays but yeah and
just things like you know when you
you you end up in this world of business
and you know there's things that you
find out about
you know like eis seis
and stuff like that and i just i just
couldn't believe
this stuff existed and it was like yeah
when you you know if you you know i've
got someone uh
jason um who invested in crepes and
cones and stuff like that and you know
had no idea about eis and scis and that
he could get you know a percentage of
his investment back and you know from
tax that he's
very previous and this is like
what
why don't we know about this like why is
this
you know there's so much like even
research and development you know you've
been able to claim money back from that
and it's like
a lot of people have probably watching
this have no idea what i'm talking about
and it's just like why
why don't why why is this stuff not
normalized or people knowing about this
stuff because there's so much ways to do
things you know and
there's so much different methods of
supporting you know you doing startups
or investing or there's so much things
to you know
relieve the
intense you know amount of money you
might end up spending to make that a
little bit better or you're not having
to spend as much or you being able to
claim this back as
it's crazy and i just feel like it's
proper hidden and as you as you you know
you get further and further into
a different world
you you find out about a lot of things
that you didn't know about before when
you first started getting money what
were you spending it on um when i first
first got my i think the first thing i
probably bought was a car
like are you good with money yeah back
then back then i wasn't bad with money
like i wasn't bad with money i
i always thought i want to you know
there's there's nice things that i
really really want to get like i wanted
a nice car and this time and forth but i
i wasn't really
like over
crazy going crazy with money i haven't
been like that um i feel like i've
always been you know good at managing
money putting money aside budgeting
money
i feel like i'm really really good at
that what advice would you give to
people then that are young especially
young people that are
you know about to embark on their own
career and that might if they're lucky
come into money what advice would you
give them um
you know try not to upgrade your actual
lifestyle
as much as
you feel like you should straight away
because
the thing about money is this it's not
even the short term of it it's the long
term of
living costs and
that lifestyle that maintaining that is
expensive because you know you might
think yeah i've got x amount of money
i'll go buy this i've still got that
it's nice because over time you got to
keep spending that money these bills are
going to keep rolling in you've got to
keep paying for this car you got to keep
paying for this house you got to keep
paying for all these bills you got to
keep you want to go out and have fun on
holiday you want to keep this is you
know so my thing is if you do get more
money try to keep the same lifestyle as
much as close as to what you was already
living
you know because it's the silent
direct debits and the silent non-stop
bills and the silent favors here and
there and the silent holiday it's that
is the silent killer of what happens to
people the lifestyle do you think that
like hip-hop culture is guilty of of
encouraging people though to upgrade
it is you know i mean because it is i
think most of my when i think about
where i was buying bottles of don peron
in nightclubs the minute i got money
it's definitely because of music videos
you know what i mean no there there is
um
but then anchors i was insecure so it's
a combination of the both it was like
yeah because you're insecure because you
were broke and you were only black in an
all-white school and you always wanted
to be have validation look at 50 cent
over here with these bottles he looks
like he's validated so yeah
no i feel like it is
[Music]
and the clubs know what they're doing as
well like
like i don't know if you ever notice but
in the club they always make it look
like people's ordering more bottles than
yeah they don't get big bottles and they
put them back in the back yeah but
to a person that's just in there they're
like oh it looks like he's just done i
need to it needs to work
yeah and it's just like it's just this
culture of them just taking your money
the thing is you know that they put
gambling shops do best in areas where
people don't have money because people
are
in those areas that's why if you go into
a more sort of deprived area you'll see
multiple gambling shops because they
they know that people in those areas to
their money means so much more and it's
a real get out so they're much more
susceptible i believe to gambling
addictions and to being reckless with
their money because if i can bet 50 quid
and get 500 that changes my life
whereas if you you're not going to see
gambling shops in rich areas
because they're not they they unders
might have the information to understand
the actual odds but b
um they don't
a big bet isn't going to change their
life in the same fundamental way they
don't have the same money in securities
and i think this is part of the problem
within within the like the like hip-hop
culture which is
a lot of people are starting out without
it so they have those insecurities about
money and money is probably the reason
for a lot of pain in their home is
probably the reason they saw their mum
and dad arguing they saw a lot of pain
around money in their home um and so
they always they always felt that it
could fill that void and then when they
get a little bit of it they're so much
more
intent and compelled to signal to
everybody else they got it yeah by
making reckless money decisions and
that's this kind of perpetual cycle
because then people are looking up at
them and going okay when i get it i'm
gonna buy the bottles of don perrion and
i'm gonna yeah and and and it's like
it's one of those ones where
it's like you can't even really
help because
you know we can make you know all of
these decisions and that show them like
look you can do these and you know
invest your money and do this do that
and fourth but to someone who is coming
from nothing
that has just got this big fat check
from a record label
you're going to tell me not to go and
buy a watch or not to buy a chain and
match everybody else that's looking you
know that you know everybody all the
girls love and this that or whatever it
is that the reason their reason for
feeling they need these things or these
items
like how do you tell them no don't do
that do this well i think it's i think
part of it is people like you who've
been through that
who they can who they trust because if
someone else says that they ain't going
to listen if their mum or dad says it
ain't been through that process who
ain't made the mistakes
i can't tell you the amount of times
i've spoken to like young
artists and said
don't go and just splash your money or
don't you don't need to go and buy
these things or buy that or you don't
need to do it and they're like yeah but
i i need the chain at least like even
maybe if it's just a chain or i need
something to look like a rapper that's
what i'm saying so it's like
self-fulfilling it's a cycle yes they're
going well if i don't get the chain then
i'm not that rapper who i want to be
someday so if that rapper that they
wanted to be someday was talking about
investing and starting companies and and
all that stuff they might be saying i
need to invest this money in the stock
market or i need to buy a property
because skeptics just bought you know
what i'm saying but the issue is is you
know
they they they need to understand that
that is a longer game
and it's more about the future but as a
rapper that might blow up now
they're going to get these bookings and
be on these television programs and be
in these clubs and being these parties
with the artists
that are
shining that have the good watch on that
has this they are going to be around
that so that's immediate
you know so telling someone you know
forget their media
think about the long term but they're in
the media every single day and
witnessing the immediate now how do you
tell them to ignore that it's hard
so even when i you know i sit down and
have you don't get me wrong like there's
there are a lot of people that do listen
and
you know do you want to
do other things and you know that have
come and asked me for advice and asked
me to intro to
introduce them to this person or that
person and i i'll always do that
but there's definitely been a lot that's
like nah but i definitely need the chain
i need i need to at least have you know
a bus down rolex i need it like i need a
bus down like everybody's been saying
you know you watch all the
you know big artists in the world
they've all got crazy chains on like you
know you look at hov jay-z he's one of
our biggest you know the people that we
look up to as a musician and a
businessman
he's got on a sick watch every time i
see a new picture of him or he's got you
know i'm saying he's got a big chain
like he's still there's still that
element i feel like
for artists the compromise is both like
go and do that stuff but
you still need to do that stuff don't
just do everything and buy you know
spend your money and splash your money
on cars and jewelry and this don't do
that maybe you know if you want to do
get your little starter pack and you
know be on your way cool but don't you
know go and spend all of your money or a
big chunk of your money on that like you
know if you want to do that do it in
you know other stages or do it in
you know you don't have to do all at
once i guess i understand that the point
as well that like this is branding at
the end of the day it is like it is like
but behind jay-z you do have one hell of
a portfolio same with diddy like you
have an unbelievable property portfolio
art collection
he's made crazy bets but you're right he
especially in the early days before yeah
yeah
he did like
it's brand new in it and you know
it's hard because i feel like for for a
lot of new young
artists knowing everything they've ever
wanted was to be like that rapper
they're watching and become
to then turn around and be like no don't
do that i completely agree i just i feel
like they have to go through it what
they wanted though was to be validated
and they wanted to fit in and they
wanted to be accepted
because when you go through it yeah
you're right it's like oh you're you're
yeah but is there not that's what i'm
saying like this is so systemic that
it's not as easy as i'm it sounds like
i'm making out like it's a really deep
systemic system yeah like just held in
place back and i realized that when i've
tried to have conversations and try to
be like you know this is what you need
to do and if you want to introduce this
you should put your money into this and
they're just like
yeah yeah okay all right
and then they go and
buy the next
you know i'm saying chain that or
pendant or whatever it is
what you're doing now is the best the
best possible thing
and that exactly
and
like it's a lot deeper than just you
know a brand it's more
the fact that
what kind of brand
what you are
and showing them that okay i can
actually do
anything then or you know
the sky's the limit and them actually
seeing that this is just as big
if not bigger than music because it's an
example that they're following they're
following the example of the one the
rapper that they admire that came before
them so words are [ __ ] great right
whatever like they're not as powerful as
an example
exactly that's what role models are so
so it's just actually going and and
doing the things yeah them seeing it and
they'll be seeing all this stuff you've
been doing not everyone will be seeing
it and they'll be thinking hmm okay yeah
and it will spark a lot of
people to think
you know what let me do that idea that i
had in my head a year ago yeah like why
not because you know
at me being a rapper
to launch you'd never put a rapper
launching a baby skincare line in the
same sentence
like it's just
it doesn't make sense even though it
makes so much sense for my life because
i have a child in the door and and it
makes sense but just
the fact that i've turned that into
something and then them actually seeing
that okay
what it is is actually
a good thing like it's not
you know there's i feel like there's one
thing putting
your name to a brand or saying this is
my brand go and buy it
and then actually another thing actually
bringing something out
that
in that market
there's a crazy demand for and they're
actually loving it for anyone that
doesn't have the context um you've
launched nylah's baby which is a um a
child care as child skin care yeah skin
and hair care um range named after your
daughter
yes and this is actually how we first
met because i was filming dragons then
in manchester we were both in this
restaurant called tattoo it's my friends
one of my friend's restaurants great
restaurant go check it out one of my
favorite restaurants actually yeah
yeah it's just basically
um and you came over and said you know
you introduce yourself because i think
we've been we have big dm on
yeah yeah but we obviously never met
face to face and that's one of the first
things you told me about you said i'm
launching this brand in in a week or two
or whatever it was and you after that
you sent me the deck of it
and uh i couldn't believe it i was sat
there with peter jones and deborah meade
meaning all the dragons i was like man
this guy's [ __ ] launching this sick
brand and it's going into 400 boot
stores because i've just been in the
dental day listening to entrepreneurs
trying to figure out how to get into
like i don't know
they're like having one of them's having
a meeting with boots and they're just
getting like blackballed or they're
getting like sidelined or whatever and
for you to come up to me but oh we're
wearing 400 boot stores i'm like that's
the investment i was looking for all day
you know what i mean i've been looking
at hand sanitizer
and you got all the [ __ ] set up before
you even dropped it you had seven
figures of investment you had this cap
table these investors that are
celebrities and that are you know big
names and that legit people and you said
yeah i'm about to drop this brand in in
a week or two um and 400 boot stores i
couldn't quite believe it i was like
that's mad and why doesn't why isn't
people why you know why isn't everybody
talking about this and then a week or so
later everyone was talking about it yeah
because i hadn't announced it then right
they were still i was
basically like a week or two away from
actually announcing it right and
um yeah so it was like it was one of
those ones but it was like even
explaining to you i was like he's
probably thinking how comes i've never
heard of it or why but because we we
hadn't announced it at that point but
the amount of preparation that went into
even just the announcing to the launch
how long did that whole project two
years two years like two years before
before nala was born
um
basically how it how it started was
sasha who's nala's mum um was pregnant
with nyla and
she became really like
i want everything natural we're having a
baby i want the best for her
as as mother's dude you know i mean and
that she got introduced to an app
it's like a product
rating ingredient app um called think
dirty so it rates products from 0 to 10
so 10 being the absolute worst and 0
being the cleanest
so we're getting you know baby shower
gifts and loads of people are giving us
kiss and loads of them are products and
you know skincare haircare products
so
we're putting all of these products
in the app
and
all of these products you know they're
claiming this that's that and the fourth
and
a lot of the products are coming up as
eights and
fives and like
looking for the zero like is there any
zero zeros here like because it
literally rates each individual
ingredient so zero is a good score zero
is the best score so that means it has
zero bad ingredients in there and like
it highlights each ingredient of what
number it gives each each ingredient and
how harmful and you can click in here it
gives you the details it's really
detailed and you know farah so i was
like
there's no zero rated like baby range in
any of these
any of the brands that we're getting
because all the brands like they're
available in all the
high street retailers and stuff so i'm
just like
nah this just can't be right and she was
like i don't want to use anything
on her and she's born because why is
there no and then we did see like a few
random zeros
here and there but you know they're
either really expensive
you know talking like 20 pound a bowl 25
pound a bottle or whatever it is
or they're from another country they're
not even sold here
um so
you know when she kind of brought this
to my attention it was like me having my
business hat and was like
you just like why don't we
why don't we make
make it why don't we make that and then
we thought is there a reason why there
isn't maybe maybe there's a reason maybe
it's not feasible or what's the reason
why isn't there why doesn't this exist
and then um
it was like all right cool
where do we even start
and then
i reached out to
someone um
i don't i'm not sure if she wants me to
say her name on that because she's
really like private but she's a g and i
i brought the idea to her
and
she was like
this is a sick idea and um funny enough
i met
an amazing manufacturer like a week ago
so i will present this to them and see
if it's something that they want would
want to do
um but let's let's mock up the branding
and let's get the branding right so that
you know when we bring it to them they
can kind of vision it
so you know we're working back and forth
in with the branding and we're like yes
this is it this this looks exactly how
we want it to look
and
um she took it to the manufacturers and
the manufacturers was like let's do it
like
this sounds like an amazing you know
idea um you've clearly done research and
you clearly have a usp and you know know
exactly what you want for this product
so this sounds like a journey that we
would love to embark on so you know
getting the tick from the manufacturer
was important for us you know because
there's loads of and you know she was
one of the people as well getting her
stabbed saying yeah i think like this
would be great
and um
so
we've
started developing
the formula
and you know they was like okay so what
do you want i was like
look
i want a brand a skincare range not just
a you know one sku but like the whole
range
it needs to for one be a zero rating on
this app
all the ingredients need to be a zero
okay we'll get to that
i said i want it to be 100 percent
natural as the most natural you can get
it and then they came back and and was
like you know 100 isn't what we would
advise for kids because you know
microbes and fungus growing on products
you need shelf life so you know you need
to have a preservative in it and and
there's different types of pros there's
natural alternatives
um
and it was like okay cool we just want
it to be the most natural you can
possibly
get that we want it to be as naturally
derived as possible and we wasn't going
to settle
and there was that and then there was
the checklist of the parent checklist of
you know vegan
cruelty free you know tear free so if it
goes in their eyes it doesn't burn
alcohol-free
all of these
sensitive skin eczema
and then you know because we took so
long formulating it nala was born and
she had eczema so that was like you know
it needs to be suitable for eczema it
needs to not irritate eczema
it needs to you know be suitable for
sensitive skin at least we need all of
these checklists and then there was like
okay that's great and then we was like
but we want it to be about five pounds
550. and that's where it was like
okay this is gonna be really kind of
difficult to do because it's like if you
want such a great product it's gonna
cost a lot and then it made me realize
why there's this doesn't exist maybe
maybe i still don't know but why doesn't
this exist and it was like
we've got to really take a hit on the
margins but
if we believe that we can make a great
product and sell loads of units then you
know it's about the mass amount of sales
rather than the niche market that can
afford an expensive product and
and do you you started this business
with your ex partner yes at the time
when you started this business were you
still together yes we was so you
actually
you separated in the time of formulating
the business yeah we did a lot of people
i mean obviously for a lot of people
that would have been it yeah and you got
broken up but you know i feel like one
thing we've definitely prioritized is
putting our daughter first
and you know we feel like this is
something that
if we get it right it can be something
we can pass down to our daughter or or
you know her to be proud of
you know because we you know when she's
older we might not even be in a company
store i don't know what could anything
can happen we might not even be here
well do you know what the company's
valued at
r1 yeah at the moment 17 and a half 17.5
million yeah
based on
the orders that obviously the amount
stores are in the orders
and that wasn't even including like d2c
it was just based on
you know our orders from
boots and
ray of sale that was expected to hit
which we've absolutely smashed since
launching but
um
yeah um and the investment as well so i
mean i've been seeing online it's been
selling out like crazy and well it's
like my team has put in order like
hundreds of thousands of bottles yeah
hundreds of thousands of bottles
maybe in me like
guys
this is a lot of bottles like
this is a lot of bottles like are we
sure we need to buy this many bottles
and what martina look trust me
we know what we're doing and then
we're about a week and a half in and i
ran out of box
and we've already put in
the order for the
the next
um cycle of production already and that
was meant to last us three months and
we've done all of our bottles in
a week and a half out today we're not
nearly two weeks people are literally
can't find it going to the stores that
sold out so i saw people selling it on
ebay it was cr it was crazy like people
literally people are still trying to get
hold of it they're going into i get
messages
every day people talking i can't it's
not available it's not available it's
not available and we've just literally
had to you know sold out on our website
our stock gone like everything was just
selling that everywhere it was like it
became like gold dust people was like oh
my god i finally i managed to get one
bottle it was only a conditioner but you
know when you restock it
it's crazy and we just did not see
this
we knew it was gonna it was like we i
knew it was gonna do
like well in terms of like i thought
people would resonate this because it's
actually a really amazing product
but
it's actually exceeded everyone's
expectations and you know now boots is
like yo
we need a lot more stock and it's like
how have we
got to place another order already of
making more stock to be available and
it's just like
at this rate like this rate of sale like
what we valued our thing was before it's
like
we definitely undervalued ourselves here
based on what's what what's happening
here
and you know now we've got to think oh
my god we've actually got to think about
the next phase of investment now because
you know
we're going to be looking to to expand
we're going to be looking to expand i'm
going to make you an offer
i'm going to offer the money
we're literally just in or of like
everything that's happened and you know
everybody coming in and
trying to make it work and you know
boots cooperating and you know really
being like really like you know
supportive of everything that's going on
and what have you learned
what i've learned is
as it relates to like you know people
listening to this that might have their
own ideas or they might be thinking
about setting up their own business what
what have you what have you learned from
this you know this process over the last
two years of building this brand that
you that you didn't know before
what i've learned i feel like this is
the first time
that i've been able to fully prepare for
something
in terms of
you don't need to rush the process
because initially when
you know
we was doing this brand i was so excited
about the brand and when it's wanted it
out and it was like i could have you
know done this brand a lot quicker cut
corners could have i could have you know
when they sent us the first batch of
samples been like yeah
not gone back and said no i don't like
this i want to change this what's the
percentage i want i want more i want it
more natural i want it more just someone
and now now we need to you know
do this test and that test and this and
it was like
i didn't have to do all of that i could
have literally just you know
got the brand after the first batch of
samples which is in the first couple
months or whatever and been like yeah
let's just get it online i didn't need
to
you know
take my time
we took our time like any time there was
a
uh
obstacle
and it would cause us to push back and
it was like do you want to push back or
do you want to just go ahead now just
push it back let's just keep pushing it
back because we need everything perfect
we need we don't want to rush this
process you know if something needs to
be changed and it was like i think we've
got it got something back and it was at
like
95 or something and natural and was like
no if it's going to take us another
month two months to get it to the 99
i'm just gonna wait what have you
learned about um the importance of one
of the first lessons i learned in
business was
because i'd also made the mistake
previously
and then when i got it right i realized
how important it was is the like what
have you learned about the importance of
the people around you especially you're
going into an area that you've not been
in before retail even like the baby
market it's a brand new area so you've
got to have surely you've got to have
people that
no
know that world yeah like these are
unknown unknowns to you like you going
into that it's the same with me and most
new areas that i've been in in terms of
industries i don't even know what i
don't know
of course and you know what one thing
i've i've
i've done with this is i let that
experts be experts in
in certain aspects and the issue is that
how do you know they're experts because
you don't even know if they're good you
don't but all you can do is based on you
know prior work
your relationship with them and them
knowing what they're talking about
um and
you know you can only gauge it to as
much as your brain can gauge something
to and you've got to kind of put trust
in it whether you might have to replace
this or place that person or this or get
someone else to do that it happens in
business all the time but you know i
feel like i've been a good judge of
character so far because everybody
that's been in my team from the start is
still here now isn't it funny how good
people hire good people 100 and bad
people high bad people 100
it's probably the single biggest thing i
think i could impress upon anyone from
this conversation as well because i know
you had you said you've had that
experience with craps and cones it's
just like there'll be young people
thinking about starting a business and
those first decisions about who they do
it with will be the single biggest
predictor of their successful failure as
far as from my experience like those
first few people
if you pick a if you pick if you take
your time and really be ambitious with
the talent you align yourself with you
say you know why can't i work with the
best person in the world than this not
not just dave who ain't got a job and
he's got time on his hands who i've who
i know went to school with like why
can't i find the best person in the
world and inspire them to come with me
on this and to form my blind spot people
don't do that 100
and also the other reason we don't do
that and why i didn't do that when i
started my business is because i don't
think i can manage
the best person in the world someone
even double my age i don't i don't know
what [ __ ] i'm talking about so how am i
going to tell them what to you know i
mean and that's an insecurity that means
we just go for dave 100 i can't remember
who said it they were saying something
like
that they if you if you're in a room or
around people where
you know you feel like you shouldn't be
there i can't remember where i was where
i was watching someone say that and it
was like you should always feel like you
shouldn't be here like you're the
dumbest person in the room yeah like
yeah you know if you feel like you're
smarter you shouldn't be yeah then you
shouldn't you shouldn't be in and you
should always feel uncomfortable like as
in like almost like you shouldn't be
here yeah yeah like and those are the
rooms that you should be in or those are
the people that you need to be trying to
you know
bring on the journey with you and that's
the growth room yeah and that's the
growth room and you can't be afraid of
that you've got to be able to go in
there and say like look this is who i am
this is what i know
and this is what i'm doing
and
do you want to embark on this journey
with me and not feel a way to do that
because i feel like a lot of people
might be shy to go and approach this
person or you know say like even even me
coming to you
you've seen 100 million people talking
about business to show you the business
i'm doing yeah
and you know being able to just feel
confident and enough to do that some
people would have thought you know
because
you're the first person that will pick
apart something you know what i'm saying
okay so this doesn't make sense
so i was just like
you know but i i've learned to just
be that person and not be afraid to you
know
go and approach someone who might be ten
times more experts in this field than me
and i don't feel scared to do that
because that's the only way i'm gonna
grow
quick one we have a brand new sponsor on
this podcast which i'm very excited to
tell you about they're a brand called
blue jeans by verizon and they are a
video conferencing and collaboration
tool that has changed the game for our
team so i'm so glad to be working with
them because as you know one of the most
important things for me is when we have
a sponsor it is part of my world it is
part of my life it is part of my
companies as someone who's on calls
pretty much 80 of the day building my
businesses and speaking to my teams all
over the world it's the guaranteed
security that differentiates blue jeans
from all of the other options that are
out there in terms of video conferencing
their enterprise grade security means
you can protect your organization from
malicious attacks and establish real
trust with everyone that joins your
meeting and that is something there are
so many things that make sense and make
blue jeans um a better option than the
sort of competitors out there and i'll
be talking about all of those aspects
those features and the reasons why i use
blue jeans in the coming episodes if you
want to check it out you can head to
www.bluejeans.com
to learn more
for many years people have been asking
for a coffee flavoured heel and quite
recently he'll release the iced coffee
caramel flavor of their um ready to
drink heels and i've just become hooked
on it over the last couple of weeks and
now i'm drinking that as well as the
protein make sure you try the new ready
to drink flavors that the caramel flavor
is amazing the new banana flavor as well
is amazing and obviously as i said the
iced coffee caramel flavor has been a
real smash here so check it out let me
know what you think on social media i
see all of your tags and instagram posts
and tweets about you
back to the podcast
i want to talk to you about
music
as well before we finish
um one of the things that i
i almost couldn't believe because it
just feels like the most unfortunate
timing ever is that you're attacked
backstage
yeah
i was yeah i was backstage and then like
loads of people just come backstage and
then they they they was asking about
someone who had no idea what he was
talking about i was it was just a mad
confusing hole
and then
someone
grabbed my chain my cadet
my cousin
and then i just remember seeing knives
like
like literally like my jacket was
like
it was crazy like i just all i remember
is seeing i had to fight my way through
it to get through the door to close the
door
but
yeah and then i looked down and my
jacket was just full of rips and then i
looked at my leg and i was soaking my
hand was bleeding like it's like it was
crazy
and um i remember the ambulance was like
if this was a millimeter deeper you
would have got your artery on your leg
and it would have been a different
scenario
and it was a bunch of
guys i don't even know who they are
never met them never had issue with them
black don't it was crazy in in
birmingham because they just rushed
backstage but
yeah it's crazy and
that um
yeah no that wasn't really in like it
wasn't right yeah it was just a
completely different um thing
but it was like
nash and cadet passing within the same
year that was
the real like
they were on the same year but within a
year so nash passed in the summer
of 2018 then cadet passed
um
four days after my birthday five days
after my birthday right cadet passed in
february
so who's for people that don't know who
is i mean cadet in and of itself is
is very well known very well love but
who is cadet to you cadet is
my cousin my first cousin um
my dad and his dad are brothers
and
he
was a musician as well and
he passed just you know he was just
having his break record
and his record was was growing and like
he was really in he's
you know that moment where you're about
to just
and he was there and he passed away in a
car accident on the way to a show
um
which
which was just like
it was crazy because
um
just like a few
weeks prior
my uncle cadet's father
just told us he'd been diagnosed with a
brain tumor
and
that
he i remember him just saying and i
don't know what i'm gonna do
and
that was the last you know so we began
mentally preparing for my uncle
and then they saying the doctors are
saying that you know i've got a couple
months
at max
and
we was trying to get through
that um and then two weeks later
cadet passes
in a car accident
on the way to a show
um and he was in a full car and he was
the only one that passed away
which
was like
it was crazy and it just makes me feel
like you know if something's destined
for you
then it's destined for you because there
were so many variables that
that could have changed that situation
in terms of
you know he was coming around a corner a
blind corner
and the guy that was driving was drunk
driving a van and he they crashed on the
corner on a country road
so if
cadet was 10 seconds later or 10 seconds
earlier
that wouldn't have happened
and there was like variables of he
missed the cab before
so there was many getting an earlier cap
we missed that then they had to call
another one
and then again in that in that cab and
then the other variable was they wasn't
even going to get a cab there there was
many actually just drive to the show but
the person that was meant to drive them
couldn't end up making it so then
they've had to go there and then you
know
get a cab and there was so much
different vape and it just was like 10
seconds five seconds even so it was a
drunk driver that he dropped the driver
oh yeah he was drunk and he and he drove
head on into the taxi
and the car was full and he was behind
the taxi driver
and it the impact on his head is what
killed him
he was he was more than just a cousin to
you there wasn't a yeah like he was
my whole life like
we grew together like as in
like my mum was at
his birth his mum was at my birth like
from they dot we've been
like this
you know land
like we grew together
we
done everything together shared so much
first memories together and then
we had like a little moment of
or period
where our relationship became rocky
because
i started
being successful in music
and he wanted to do music as well and
because it was the same argument of him
it was like you need to you need to go a
bit more harder with this music you need
to do this you need to do that
and
so we invited him to wireless
um we was performing at wireless
festival
and was like just come
like get inspired
we've got we've got we're about to
perform he's going to be sick
and
he
came and i remember he was like i'm so
charged i'm so charged
and then he you know he got in the
studio he was like sending me loads of
mute he was like it was a whole
different energy and then you know you
could feel that energy
you know being resonated with you know
fans and audience and then he started
really building
this you know following and he's you
know he was really great at storytelling
like he was an amazing storyteller and
people loved that about him and he
you know
it just started all happening for him
and then
before he died i remember he done a um
he put like a clip of him doing a song
with another artist called dino
like they put a clip up and then i
remember
kona was saying to him like
turn this into a song
make this a song this is make this an
actual record that song now has gone you
know to be platinum
selling and it was independent
and you know we was having those
conversations about money
he was like we because we was like look
this song's picking up you're about to
see really good money and he was like
yeah but it's not here now and i'm
saying yeah because it takes a while to
get processing for you to receive it but
and he's like shall i sign the record
shall i sign it to a label because the
label will offer me you know 100 grand
150 grand right now for i'm saying no
this song is already doing what it's
doing without any label just do it
independently and just
[Music]
let it build it and you'll make so much
more than what they're offering and he
was like all right cool that's what i'm
going to do and then songs kept getting
bigger and bigger no it's silver
two hundred thousand copies three
hundred thousand copies it was just
growing and then
you know he was finally having that
moment where he was about to you know
break through and
then he had the
accident
and then it was just like
everything just came crashing down
and that was like
within the same
like within a year of
nash passing away and that was
like my best friend
and then blaine passing away
cadet's name's playing
passing away
you know
within months after that and i've just
lost these two pillars in my life
within a year
whilst being told my uncle's gonna die
do you remember where you were when you
found out
yeah i was
in
dubai
um
my partner at the time sasha
um
took me to dubai for my birthday
and
um we was i was packing
and walking in the lobby to go to the
airport back to come back
so i was on the way back to london
and then my friend cj
was calling me by the time that it was
it was at like it was like 2 a.m or 1 2
a.m in london
and i think it was like
6 00
6 a.m where i was i was like four hours
difference or something but i just
remember looking at the phone yeah
i'm thinking
because cj doesn't call me
but he's really close with cadet
but so he doesn't call me like as in
like he wouldn't he was not one to call
me at that time of night for anything
so i'm looking at my phone
and i don't know how my brain processed
that there was an issue
in such a short time
he called me i was like
the time in the uk is
2am cj never calls me
why is he calling me something's gone
wrong he's him and blaine are like this
something's gone wrong with blaine
and i answered the phone i just
done all of that like straight away i
was just like this doesn't make sense
and i've answered the phone and he's
literally crying on the phone
and i knew
straight away like i knew
i didn't know what how
like sorry i didn't know how or i just
knew that something was wrong and it was
to do with blame because he's calling me
and
he's just crying on the phone crying on
the phone and i'm just like what what
what what
and then he said he's gone
and he didn't need to say
blaine cadet he didn't need to say that
because i knew exactly who he was
talking about
and then he said
and he but he wasn't talking properly he
was like car crash
like he's gone he's gone he's gone
like
and then i just remember like i ran out
of breath i was
i had to lean on something like i my
breath was going like
i felt like i was literally gonna drop
down and faint in the middle of the
hotel
and
i was just like i didn't even know
what to feel like i'm about to get on a
plane i've just found out my cousins
passed away
and i'm
you know stuck in an airplane like this
whole time i'm just going through
customs and doing this i'm doing this
but i've just found out my cousin's
dying and i'm just like
get to me back
now
like it was one of the worst
if not the worst feeling
not ever like losing him
was
uh like ah it was horrible like it was
horrible and
you know he was
such an important person in my life like
i would speak to him about everything
like every idea
every song i play it to him like
every just everything like he was like
everything to me you know i mean and to
lose him
it was just
it was hard it's horrible and just
something we're still
dealing with still dealing with it until
today still
i still i haven't even taken my thought
off the gas since
to sit down and actually take in that
he's not here
up until today i haven't
do you remember the last thing that you
that blaine said to you
yes
the last thing he said to me was
um just know that i love you for real
for real and i've got your gucci socks
for your birthday
that was the last thing he said to me
and
i was congratulating him on getting his
first apartment
because he just got his apartment and he
was like yo i'm really feeling like
starting to feel like a ref now like i'm
starting to feel like
um and yeah and he was like i've got
these gucci socks here for you and you
when you're back for a number meaning i
was in dubai
and that was the last time we spoke
i can see you're still processing it
wow
what's in your mind
i just feel like
you should be here man
and
witnessing everything
and
like i just felt like it was too soon
like he was on the brink of doing
something great
and it was just like it
just
got taken away from him and
yeah it just felt too soon like you know
when someone has so much to to offer
like he has so much to offer the world
he was like
he's
presence was so infectious
like he's that person that will come
somewhere and you just you'll remember
him
because like he's
such a troll comedian makes you laugh
so positive hasn't got a bad bone in his
body like he's
he's the person he was the person that
will tell you
all the friends i love you bro
and everyone's like oh rob stop saying
like he would yeah i love you and he
would say look you dead in your house
and say yeah i love you
and he didn't feel
a way
to say that and he you know he was
always so expressive and he made us feel
comfortable to be like i love you man i
love you too i love you too like my
brother i love you like and you know
he was that guy and you know
he had the most infectious laugh
like he was so honest with you know when
you're trying to make a decision he'll
give you the most honest opinion if you
think something's not good or nothing
something's terrible idea
like
he was that person man and
[Music]
he was a big part of me
so that's why i feel like i haven't
and don't want to sit down and process
it
and
it's not easy you know
we buried up not buried but
my uncle got cremated but
his funeral was yesterday
so
he passed away a few weeks ago
he gave him a few months he lived
an extra few years
so it was a fire
but
i've lost both of them
and
like
they're both
important
role models in my life like
my uncle was
he was the guy you know i mean like
he was the responsible
the guy like my dad is more than
you know i can go and do something with
my dad that we shouldn't be doing like
he's that guy and you know i'm
saying me and my dad are really close
now do you know what i mean but my uncle
was always that
if i need advice or
this is what i'm going through or
what should i do here and
you know
even talking to him about knowledge and
them saying like
you know you should do this right get
investment well in those moments when
you realize that life can be unfair and
precious and equal measure
people often speak about things words
that went unsaid things they wish they
could say in hindsight something that i
think a lot about with my parents as
well i try and reflect on the fact that
they're not going to be here forever and
that there's certain things i wish i
should probably be saying to them now
that at some point when i realized which
we
life teaches us in the most unfortunate
ways that
life is finite it's not guaranteed and
it is precious that um we realize when
it's too late and people as they say get
the roses um
after they can smell them definitely is
there anything that you when you reflect
on words you you you wish you could have
said to him or you wish you could say
now that that
um that comes to mind is there anything
where you go do you know i wish in
hindsight now i know how precious life
is i wish that this had been different
or
um
no but
he did teach me a very valuable lesson
because
otherwise i would have had that regret
and that would have been eating me up
until today was
us sorting out our little issues that we
had
and
becoming close again and not letting
that drag out because
if we didn't
yeah i would have lived in regret for
the rest of my life the fact that i
didn't
you know put them in a hug hug hug hug
through it and
turn our page and and get on with what
we are as cousins blood and family and
you know we've been in each other's
lives forever we trust love each other
like
if i didn't
rectify that situation we didn't rectify
that situation how would i felt so
it's definitely taught me from there
when i have issues
with people
that are close to me or arguments with
family members
let's forget that sort it out now we've
gotta sort out now let's argue let's
scream at each other now but let's do it
now
and let's hug afterwards
that's what it's taught me i don't want
to you know live and regret and think
ah
like the last conversation we had was he
was arguing wasn't even talking
our words were harsh or
you know because that can happen
and also other little moments of
spending time
you know
i feel like especially even after
yesterday and just
seeing my family
that was at blaine's funeral
at my uncle's funeral and thinking that
if this was me
these are the same people that are going
to be there for me
this is who i need to be focusing my
time and energy on
because these are the people that care
the most
not saying no one don't care
but as in these are the people that are
going to be here if this happens to me
who's these are the people that are
lifting my uncle's casket that is going
to go and lift my casket
this is where i need to to really focus
and spend my time because
everything else
is great
it's it's lovely but
you know
anything can happen to me and that means
nothing
and then it means everything to my
family do you think you need to um
confront some of those things that
you've kept yourself distracted from
confronting the grief the loss i do and
how how do you think you'd go about
doing that because i've heard you speak
about and encourage other people to go
to therapy before and have those
conversations but from what i was able
to ascertain that's not something you've
done you have to i haven't done therapy
i'm not
i i just i just felt like you know if
someone feels like they want to go
therapy don't feel weird by going to
therapy i don't know why that was even
even seems as weird at a stage or not
even weird sorry it used to be
stigmatized yeah
like whatever it was but it's not it's
just it's normal but
i haven't done it
because i feel like i'm on this
treadmill yes
and that's why i haven't done it and i
feel like therapy is gonna be the thing
to
make me actually take everything in and
i thought maybe i'm scared to go for a
fee
maybe but i feel like i should
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks the
next guest a question they don't know
who they're writing it for and i don't
get to read the question until i open
this book so yeah
um
interesting
these are always quite difficult because
they're always quite profound but um
when was the last time
you changed your mind
about something life-changing
i think the last time i changed my mind
was
nila's baby
the fact of you know we just broke up
and we had that yeah no we're not gonna
do this because this
might make sense
and then having that
you know what
nah i've gotta put our daughter first
changed changed my mind let's do it
let's do it let's do it let's do it
let's do it and it was like okay cool
let's do it
and you know i feel like
what we're about to achieve
with that
god willing
you know
was a life-changing decision
it's interesting because when i reflect
on the story you've shared with me today
there was another moment where you had
to make a big decision sat in that car
after conan was conan's family was
attacked yes and it's funny in hindsight
how you can see
how a decision just in the opposite
direction that could have happened
through emotion in the moment a decision
not to choose maturity or to put
something more important first could
have sent your life in a completely
different direction
just for temporary feelings you know a
decision you can make can make a
permanent outcome and it's just like
yeah think about it
crap
thank you for your time it's been i mean
it's been incredibly inspiring to to
meet you to get to know you to see what
you've done and i don't know i feel like
life might have
you know made us cross paths for a
reason because i was thinking a lot
about a lot of things to do with like
money and investing and how you know how
to be a better role model for the next
generation of people and young people
from slightly challenging backgrounds
and then i'd met you that day
you were doing this incredible thing
with nyla's baby and um
it was like the universe had conspired
to inspire me at that exact moment
um to
make sure that your story and what
you're doing becomes the role model
becomes the the thing that young people
are aspiring to do because not only did
you have huge success in this one area
of hip-hop music and rap and and those
things but for you then to go into a
completely unexpected
a slightly bizarre to be honest
the babywear industry
it's the most perfect example of like
resisting your labels your labels told
you to be a rapper to wrap
but
in resisting your labels you went into a
completely different area where you're
absolutely not allowed to be
according to yes society and for you to
make a huge success there i think is the
best evidence we can all take on for our
own lives that we are not our labels we
can do anything and um
and and also um
you've given such clarity on like the
steps that we take to get there the
importance of team the importance of
hard work and and much of it is just the
importance of self-relief because
when your partner was was having those
concerns about other babyweb baby
products on the market a lot of people
would have just accepted it
they would have just taken the product
that had the eight rating but there's a
certain type of person that goes maybe
we can change this
and that's what you did so thank you for
the inspiration thank you for the
generosity of your time and thanks for
sharing your story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]